anything else did you arm so I'm dying
up here you have a special coming out
this Friday yes
this Friday July 7th the ugly truth
that's what it's called and yeah sad
about my first one on Showtime's
well that's your first special in
general no I had a half-hour on Comedy
Central but this is your real 1 hour and
it's on Netflix no it's on Showtime
Showtime Showtime Showtime Showtime
that's big you know I understand why
Netflix is acting like they can't give
everybody a special it's a [ __ ] server
just go to [ __ ] Best Buy and get some
more hard drives but don't tell me you
can't get you know no way they said no
to you yeah they said no but I hear
other people saying it's like I hear
other people saying no but I bought them
the hit thing is I made my special
myself with audible with rooftop they
produce my special known everything is
it a thing where they're doing their own
stuff I don't know if they're buying
people's things anymore yeah yeah well
my thing is like I don't want to hear
that you can't like whoever books it now
yeah like they're full of [ __ ] that's
not only that it's their choice don't
tell me about how I can't do this you
gave six like 80 million dollars to for
comics not only that got money server
space look at these play I'm not gonna
name names comics because people work
hard but there's some some of those
[ __ ] Netflix ones they don't deserve
it they need content and number one but
they get people stuff like yeah but that
was and I'm gonna name names but it's
like who's behind you yeah but there's
no distance here's what I keep don't
like about Hollywood and I'm gonna say
this is a real OK there and I this is a
fact there's a [ __ ] disconnect between
what's really happening in the club
level of LA and then what they put on TV
oh for sure it's like it's like they get
people specials and I go he can't do
with the Comedy Store yeah yeah yeah
terrible yeah yeah yeah or they can't
yeah I know or they can't I'm saying
right now that and you can say whatever
you want about me or whatever right but
this is what I know is is that you put
me up after anybody I'm gonna survive
right I think that should be the test
Yeah right I mean I I mean Martin
Lawrence Chris Rock and Chappelle could
go on at the city like back-to-back and
I can go up after I'm not saying I'm
gonna be better but I can survive yeah
nobody's gonna be like that guy doesn't
belong on the show yeah but some people
yeah they can't survive I don't get it I
don't get it either always been like
that
no but it's sort of like it's the people
the powers-that-be the people the the
bill the the gatekeepers these people
it's their taste ah and I wish a gate
keepers like Comedy Central should work
like [ __ ] casting directors like that
they should it should work like the NFL
like if you're a general manager of a
team and your team goes 3 and 15 four
years in a row yeah guess what you lose
your [ __ ] job yeah yeah but network
executives they put out pilots that they
decide oh this is gonna be great
oh this is gonna be great and then the
ratings suck and you know yeah but they
do change the taste I understand the
change that's all I mean like comedies
you arrange their taste every three
years some new people should come in and
they they try to do something different
that's the same [ __ ] you know it's
like oh they gotta be artsy and
pretentious and like you gotta make
comics comics laughs like you know if
they if they laugh that's fine I like
comics comics but I'm tax just thank you
for specials to open my curse bro it's a
niche it's not a niche no because what
it is is this all right it's like a
comedy fetish no the people in charge
with the [ __ ] decisions right there
are middle men in the middle men are the
agents and managers and they spin [ __ ]
and they [ __ ] you know they they
embellish people's you know what's
halon's that's one of the few businesses
that people that are horrible at it run
it they're not funny and then they make
these choices you know we think this
person is really funny yeah they put
everything behind it and then people go
I didn't think that was funny
yeah because they don't want to even go
to the club